Souvent, la façon dont cela se produit nous informe sur les planètes.
Car, en pensant au système solaire,
vous pensez peut-être à cette image.
Et vous diriez qu'il y a huit planètes, peut-être neuf.
Pour ceux d'entre vous que cette image stresse,
je vais la compléter.
(Rires)
Avec l'autorisation de New Horizons, nous incluons Pluton.
Le fait est que pour cette présentation et en termes d'échappement atmosphérique,
Pluton est une planète pour moi
et les planètes que nous ne voyons pas qui sont autour d'autres étoiles
sont aussi des planètes.
Les caractéristiques fondamentales des planètes
incluent le fait que ce sont des corps
que la gravité maintient ensemble.
C'est beaucoup de matière agrégée par cette force d'attraction.
Ces corps sont si gros et ont tellement de gravité.
C'est pourquoi ils sont ronds.
Quand vous les regardez,
même Pluton,
ils sont ronds.
Vous voyez que la gravité joue vraiment un rôle.
Mais une autre caractéristique fondamentale des planètes
est ce que vous ne voyez pas,
c'est l'étoile, le Soleil,
autour duquel toutes les planètes du système solaire orbitent.
Cela est à l'origine de l'échappement atmosphérique.
La raison fondamentale pour laquelle
les étoiles créent un échappement atmosphérique sur les planètes
est que les étoiles offrent aux planètes particules, lumière et chaleur
pouvant faire s'échapper les atmosphères.
Si vous pensez à une montgolfière
ou regardez cette image de lanternes lors d'un festival en Thaïlande,
vous voyez que l'air chaud propulse les gaz vers le haut.
Si vous avez assez d'énergie et de chaleur,
comme notre soleil,
ce gaz, qui est si léger et seulement contraint par la gravité,
peut s'échapper dans l'espace.
Cela est la cause de l'échappement atmosphérique
sur Terre et sur d'autres planètes --
cette interaction entre la chaleur de l'étoile
et la compensation de la force de gravité sur la planète.
Je vous ai dit que cela se produisait
à une vitesse de 200 kg par minute pour l'hydrogène
et près de 3,5 kg pour l'hélium.
A quoi cela ressemble-t-il ?
Même dans les années 80,
nous avons pris des photos de la Terre
en ultraviolet
grâce au satellite Dynamics Explorer de la NASA.
Ces deux photos de la Terre
vous montrent à quoi ressemble cette lueur d'hydrogène qui s'échappe,
elle apparaît en rouge.
Vous voyez aussi d'autres éléments comme l'oxygène et l'azote
dans cette lueur blanche
dans le cercle vous montrant les aurores
et aussi des volutes vers les tropiques.
Ces photos montrent définitivement
que notre atmosphère n'est pas seulement liée à la Terre
mais qu'elle s'efforce d'atteindre d'autres endroits de l'espace
à une vitesse alarmante.
Mais la Terre n'est pas la seule à subir un échappement atmosphérique.
Mars, notre voisine la plus proche, est bien plus petite que la Terre
et a donc bien moins de gravité pour préserver son atmosphère.
Bien que Mars ait une atmosphère,
nous voyons qu'elle est plus fine que sur Terre.
Regardez la surface.
Vous voyez des cratères indiquant qu'aucune atmosphère
n'était là pour empêcher ses impacts.
Nous voyons que c'est « la planète rouge »
et l'échappement atmosphérique joue un rôle
quant à la couleur de Mars.
Nous pensons que cela est dû au fait que Mars avait plus d'eau auparavant
et quand l'eau avait assez d'énergie, elle s'est séparée en hydrogène et oxygène
et l'hydrogène est si léger qu'il s'est échappé vers l'espace
et l'oxygène restant
s'est oxydé ou a fait rouiller le sol,
créant cette couleur rouge rouille qui nous est familière.
C'est bien de regarder des photos de Mars
et de dire qu'il y a eu un échappement atmosphérique
mais la NASA a actuellement une sonde sur Mars, le satellite MAVEN,
et sa mission d'étudier l'échappement atmosphérique.
C'est le satellite de l'atmosphère de Mars et de l'évolution volatile.
Ses résultats ont déjà montré des images très similaires
à ce que vous voyez sur Terre.
Nous savions que Mars perdait son atmosphère
mais nous avons des photos spectaculaires.
Ici, par exemple, dans le cercle rouge,
c'est la taille de Mars
et dans le bleu, c'est l'hydrogène qui s'échappe de la planète.
Il atteint une distance de 10 fois la taille de la planète,
assez loin pour ne plus être lié à cette planète.
Il s'échappe dans l'espace.
Cela aide à confirmer certaines idées
telles que le fait que Mars soit rouge à cause de cette perte d'hydrogène.
Mais l'hydrogène n'est pas le seul gaz perdu.
J'ai mentionné l'hélium sur Terre, l'oxygène, l'azote ;
depuis MAVEN nous voyons aussi de l'oxygène s'échappant de Mars.
Vous voyez que, parce que l'oxygène est plus lourd,
il ne va pas aussi loin que l'hydrogène
mais il s'échappe quand même de la planète.
Vous ne le voyez pas confiné à ce cercle rouge.
Le fait que l'échappement atmosphérique n'existe pas que sur notre planète
et que nous puissions l'étudier ailleurs en envoyant un satellite
nous permet d'en apprendre plus sur le passé des planètes
mais aussi sur les planètes en général
et sur l'avenir de la Terre.
Une façon d'en apprendre plus sur le futur
est grâce à des planètes si lointaines qu'on ne les voit pas.
Je devrais faire remarquer, avant de continuer,
que je ne vais pas vous montrer des images de Pluton,
ce qui peut vous décevoir,
mais nous n'en avons pas encore.
La mission de New Horizons est d'étudier l'échappement atmosphérique
qui est perdu par la planète.
Restez à l'écoute sur le sujet.
Mais les planètes dont je voulais parler
sont appelées « exoplanètes en transit ».
Toute planète orbitant autour d'une étoile qui n'est pas notre soleil
est appelée « exoplanète » ou « planète extrasolaire ».
Ces planètes dites « en transit »
ont une caractéristique :
si vous regardez cette étoile, au milieu,
vous verrez qu'elle clignote.
Et elle clignote
car il y a des planètes qui passent devant elle en permanence.
Elle a une orientation particulière
qui fait que les planètes bloquent la lumière de l'étoile,
ce qui nous permet de voir l'étoile clignoter.
En surveillant les étoiles dans le ciel et en cherchant ce clignotement,
nous pouvons trouver des planètes.
Nous sommes ainsi capables de détecter plus de 5 000 planètes
dans la Voie lactée
et, comme je l'ai dit, nous savons qu'il y en a bien plus.
Nous regardons la lumière de ces étoiles
et, comme je l'ai dit, nous ne voyons pas la planète en elle-même
mais une diminution de la lumière
que nous constatons au fil du temps.
La lumière baisse alors que la planète ralentit devant l'étoile
et cela donne le clignotement vu auparavant.
Nous détectons les planètes
et nous observons cette lumière à différentes longueurs d'onde.
J'ai parlé de regarder la Terre et Mars à la lumière ultraviolette.
En observant les exoplanètes en transit avec le télescope spatial Hubble,
sous la lumière ultraviolette,
le clignotement est plus important, il y a moins de lumière venant de l'étoile
quand la planète passe devant.
A notre avis, c'est parce qu'il y a une atmosphère étendue d'hydrogène
tout autour de la planète
qui la rend plus grosse
et donc bloque plus de lumière que ce que vous voyez.
En utilisant cette technique, nous avons pu découvrir
quelques exoplanètes en transit subissant un échappement atmosphérique.
Ces planètes peuvent être appelées « Jupiter chaudes »,
en tout cas pour certaines.
Cela car, comme Jupiter, ce sont des planètes gazeuses
mais elles sont si proches de leur étoile,
environ 100 fois plus proches que Jupiter.
Et parce qu'il a tout ce gaz léger qui est prêt à s'échapper
et toute cette chaleur de l'étoile,
il y a des taux catastrophiques d'échappement atmosphérique.
Contrairement à nos 200 kg d'hydrogène perdus chaque minute sur Terre,
ces planètes perdent 0,7 milliard de kilogrammes d'hydrogène par minute.
Vous pourriez penser : « De ce fait, la planète arrête-t-elle d'exister ? »
C'est une question que les gens se posent
en regardant notre système solaire
car les planètes proches du soleil sont rocheuses
et celles plus lointaines sont plus grosses et gazeuses.
Peut-on avoir commencé avec une chose comme Jupiter
qui était proche du soleil,
et s'être débarrassé de tout le gaz ?
A notre avis, commencer avec une planète aussi chaude que Jupiter
fait que vous ne pouvez pas finir comme Mercure ou la Terre.
Mais en commençant avec une planète plus petite,
il est possible qu'assez de gaz se soit échappé
pour que cela ait un impact significatif
et que vous ayez une chose complètement différente de celle du début.
Tout cela semble assez général
et nous pensons au système solaire,
mais qu'est-ce que cela a à voir avec nous, sur Terre ?
Dans un avenir lointain,
le soleil deviendra plus brillant.
Quand cela se produira,
la chaleur que nous recevons du soleil deviendra très intense.
De la même façon que le gaz s'échappe de la planète chaude Jupiter,
le gaz va s'échapper de la Terre.
Nous pouvons nous attendre,
ou au moins nous préparer,
au fait que dans un futur lointain,
la Terre ressemblera plus à Mars.
Notre hydrogène, de l'eau qui s'est décomposée,
va s'échapper plus rapidement vers l'espace
et il nous restera une planète aussi sèche et rouge.
N'ayez crainte, nous avons quelques milliards d'années
et donc le temps de nous préparer.
(Rires)
Mais je voulais que vous soyez conscients de ce qui arrive,
pas seulement à l'avenir,
car l'échappement atmosphérique se produit en ce moment même.
Vous entendez parler de beaucoup de science extraordinaire dans l'espace
et sur des planètes lointaines,
nous étudions ces planètes pour en apprendre plus sur ces mondes.
Mais en en apprenant plus sur Mars ou les Jupiters chaudes,
nous découvrons des choses comme l'échappement atmosphérique
qui nous en disent beaucoup plus sur notre planète, la Terre.
Pensez à cela la prochaine fois que vous pensez que l'espace est lointain.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)